Привет! Это второй урок модуля System Architect. Сегодня у нас технический такой урок. Подключаем Figma MCP к лод коду. После этого урока у нас будет EDM, будет рабочий агент, который читает наши Figma файлы и умеет их редактировать, что самое главное. Итак, что такое MCP в двух словах? Мы уже затрагивали эту тему. Давай ещё раз это сделаем.
Model Context Protocol — это открытый стандарт, по которому и агент общается с внешними инструментами. Для нас внешний инструмент Figma или Notion, как было в прошлом модуле. Между код код и Figma входит протокол MCP. Подробно про устройство агентов и этот протокол мы поговорим ещё в самом последнем модуле сегодня. Для понимания этого достаточно.
Итак, план урока такой. Сначала разберём, какие бывают Figma MCP сервера, почему мы берём именно один из двух, потом пробежимся по возможностям, что конкретно агент умеет делать с файлом.
Дальше подключим MCP через директиву. Уже для вас её настроил. За пару минут всё само начнёт работать. В конце у нас первая команда и разбор подписок, которые нужны.
Итак, на данный момент у Figma MCP есть два варианта сервера. Это Desktop и Remote. Выбор между ними определяет, что агент вообще сможет делать.
Desktop сервер запускается локально через Figma приложение. Вы открываете файл Figma Desktop, переходите в DevMod, включаете MCP в inspect панели и сервер поднимается на вашей машине.
Вам на самом деле это не особо нужно, но вдруг давайте покажу, как это делается. Открываем наш файл, включаем режим разработчика, вот эта третья маленькая вкладочка.
И тут нажимаем Enable Desktop MCP Server. Всё, он запускается. Если вы делаете это в первый раз, возможно будут ещё какие-то настройки, но у вас Figma сама за руку по ним проведёт.
Мне сейчас он тут не нужен, поэтому я его выключу. Из полезного, что он умеет? Он умеет читать дизайн-контекст, переменные стили и работать с CodeConnect.
Но создавать и менять объекты на Canvas он не может. То есть это такой инструмент для разработчика, который ничего не хочет там создавать на вот этих вот Figma Frame, но ему нужно эти файлы каким-то образом себе забрать, чтобы потом сверстать.
Для него этот вариант подойдёт. Мы же будем работать через Remote Server. Он хостится на самой Figma по адресу mcp.figma.com. Он не требует десктоп-приложения, подключается через авторизацию в браузере.
И главное отличие, у него есть инструмент UseFigma, который умеет создавать и менять фреймы, переменные, компоненты, автолаяуты, то есть весь write-функционал.
Называем мы это именно write-функционал, то есть функционал записи. Если в первом случае у нас только чтение, тут у нас запись.
В модуле мы будем чистить макеты, собирать компоненты, создавать токены, всё это в write-операции. Значит нам нужен Remote.
Десктоп по архитектуре проще, но половина модуля на нём технически работать не будет, поэтому мы берём Remote.
Итак, теперь давайте немного поговорим о возможностях. Можно разделить их на 4 основные группы.
Первое из них это чтение. Агент читает структуру файла, какие есть фреймы, слои, как они названы, стили, компоненты, переменные.
Он видит абсолютно всю иерархию. То есть даже если у вас там, например, компоненты и его вариации с какими-то внутренними переменными, он всё это прекрасно видит.
Это вот база, с которой всё начинается.
Дальше у нас запись на Canvas. Это useFigma, главный в write-tool.
Агент создаёт и меняет объекты, новые фреймы, слои, переменные, стили, компоненты, авто-лей-аут и всё это он может делать.
Он переименовывает, группирует, меняет настройки.
То есть, ну, по сути, все те же операции, которые вы руками делаете, можно делать по команде агенту автоматически.
И здесь ещё давайте отмечу, что вот вы видите, у нас тут есть на слайде getDesignContext, useFigma и так далее.
Это всё команды, которые можно вызывать в чатике с клодом.
Вовсе не обязательно их все запоминать.
Ты просто ставишь задачи, он сам уже знает, какие команды для чего использовать.
Дальше, что отдельно можно отметить, это FigJam.
Тот же агент уже пишет на FigJam Canvas, он создаёт фреймы, связи, стикеры, может загенерировать целую диаграмму.
Это полезно для sitemap, userflow.
Этим мы займёмся в четвёртом уроке.
И последний, это CodeConnect.
Это маппинг Figma компонентов на код в вашем репозитории.
То есть, я уже это упоминал, связка того, что у нас в Figma, всей нашей дизайн-системы, компонентов и прочего,
с тем, что у нас в Prode или просто в прототипе не так, что ты там в Figma что-то поменял,
а в Prode это не изменилось.
Потому что агент даже не знает, что эти там два компонента связаны.
Нет, у нас взаимосвязная система.
Всё это мы будем выстраивать, но делать это мы будем в последнем четвёртом модуле.
Там мы уже говорим о прототипировании, и там это будет актуально.
Сейчас просто отметим, что такая возможность есть, и под это функционал отдельно предусмотрен.
Итак, теперь давайте перейдём к установке.
Как я уже сказал, директиву я для вас создал.
Давайте пройдём полностью по этому workflow.
Давайте я создам новый файлик для вот этого учебного проекта и назову его Learn Workspace.
Итак, теперь мы можем переходить в нашу рабочую среду в Antigravity,
либо в любой другой IDE, где ты используешь Cloud Code.
Используем мы обязательно Cloud Code.
Ещё раз напомню, как он устанавливается.
Мы открываем расширение, здесь пишем Cloud Code, устанавливаем,
и потом при открытии любых файлов мы можем нажать на вот такую иконку Клода,
и у нас откроется окно беседы с ним.
Итак, ну я могу выбрать просто этот файлик и сказать запускай.
Пока он разбирается с этой директивой, давайте посмотрим, из чего она состоит.
Она устроена таким образом, что она сразу говорит, какие файлы создавать,
как создавать это подключение по MCP по самому оптимальному способу.
И также здесь она учитывает вот эти все основные команды, которые можно использовать.
Тут также в самом начале прописано, что у нас использование этой директивы может быть в двух режимах,
когда пользователь только подключает и когда пользователь использует Figma через MCP.
С этим всем он будет сверяться в ходе вашей работы,
свежать в памяти вот эти вот названия команд.
Итак, здесь у нас настройка прошла.
Теперь он просит перезапустить VS Code расширения, Cloud Code или Desktop приложение.
И после чего можно написать готово.
Делаем это, перезапускаем его и двигаемся дальше.
Возвращаемся к разговору, пишем ему готово.
Он говорит, пришли ссылку на любой фрейм из твоей Figma.
Давай вернемся в Figma и здесь создадим какой-нибудь простенький фрейм,
чтобы он мог его описать, и мы убедились, что у нас все работает.
Возвращаемся, вставляем просто ссылку.
Если вы не перезапустили на предыдущем шаге, вот как, например, я сделал,
он говорит, что у него подключение не получилось наладить.
Перезапустил и теперь он пишет, что все, Figma MCP на месте, мы подключились, можем двигаться дальше.
Авторизация у меня прошла автоматически, скорее всего, потому что я уже это делал.
У тебя же он выдаст ссылку, скорее всего.
По ней нужно будет перейти, в браузере нажать, авторизироваться.
Именно ваш новый оплаченный аккаунт, в котором доступны возможности работы с MCP.
Не перепутайте со своим основным аккаунтом, если он, конечно, бесплатный.
И вас обратно сюда вернет, уже с возможностью взаимодействовать с MCP.
Итак, тут он нам описал, что внутри красный квадрат 365 на 365.
И он находится в белом фрейме, который называется Frame 1.
Описывает цвета, позицию.
Короче, мы точно можем убедиться, что он видит наш файл.
Итак, теперь давайте поговорим про подписках и ограничениях, о которых нужно знать.
Клод код мы уже оформили в прошлом уроке.
У нас она есть.
Нам также нужна подписка на Figma.
Там должен быть DEV или Full Seed.
На Starter Seed в Write Functional MCP не работает.
Агент сможет только читать.
DEV и Full Seed есть на любом платном плане Figma.
Итак, где их взять?
Я лично использую Figma Education.
Ее можно оформить бесплатно.
Если ты обучаешься в каком-нибудь университете.
Но сейчас в целом международные отношения напряженные.
Поэтому я подписку покупаю.
Купить ее можно сразу на полгода.
Стоит это достаточно дешево.
Ссылка, где ее купить, будет в описании под этим уроком.
Ну а если вы уже работаете в команде, в каком-то продукте,
то, скорее всего, у вас подписка есть.
И ничего дополнительно вам покупать не нужно.
Итак, по подписке также у нас еще отличаются лимиты.
На Pro плане Figma MCP у нас есть 200 запросов в день.
200 вполне достаточно.
Это кажется много.
Но если писать каждую мелкую правку отдельной командой,
то лимит может быстро закончиться.
Поэтому запоминаем, что команды мы для экономии вот этих запросов
отправляем сразу по несколько штук.
Вот, например, здесь отражено, что мы не каждый раз ему что-нибудь пишем,
типа, переименуй слои, потом применяй автолейаут,
и потом убери пустые группы.
Лучше сразу сформировать пул правок и отправить его их делать,
для того, чтобы вот эти вот запросы не тратить попусту.
Вот.
200 запросов выдается именно в день,
поэтому вот при таком подходе вам их точно с головой хватит.
Итак, по поводу домашки.
Домашка у нас будет простая.
Мы запускаем директиву Figma MCP Setup,
подключаем MCP по шагам из видео,
а потом открываем любой свой макет текущий или там создаем новый.
Что-нибудь в нем создаем внутри и делаем запрос,
опиши, что ты сейчас видишь, какие есть фреймы и так далее.
То есть просто начинаем диалог и убеждаемся,
что он видит, с чем он работает.
После чего мы это скриним и отправляем в качестве домашнего задания.
Ничего сложного делать не нужно.
Удачи с выполнением домашнего задания
и увидимся на следующем уроке.